la première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues
lundi
au premier jour du jour
plusieurs tremblements de terre ont
frappé le sud-est de la Turquie et de la
Syrie voisine
ils ont été suivis de nombreuses et très
violentes
alors que le bilan humain de cette
catastrophe
s'alourdit de jour en jour
je souhaitais que nos pensées aille aux
victimes et à leurs proches ainsi qu'aux
équipes mobilisées pour leur porter
secours
nous serons attentifs est-ce que tous
les secours nécessaires parviennent aux
populations touchées ou qu'elles se
trouvent et sans autre critère
que ceux de l'urgence
et que la France
madame la Première ministre apportera
toute sa contribution
à l'aide internationale déployée
je suis certain au nom du Sénat tout
entier
je voulais
exprimer notre solidarité au peuple turc
et syrien et les assurés de notre
soutien
madame la Première ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs au nom du
gouvernement je veux à mon tour redire
toute notre solidarité au peuple turc et
syrien dès lundi le président de la
République a annoncé la mobilisation de
notre pays est proposée une aide
d'urgence des sapeurs-pompiers des
sapeurs sauveteurs et des personnels du
centre de crise et de soutien sont
arrivés sur place il contribue aux
recherches sur le terrain pour aider les
blessés nous avons également proposé
l'envoi d'un hôpital de campagne de la
sécurité civile mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs la France est aux côtés
des peuples turcs et syriens dans cette
épreuve je vous remercie
[Musique]